It is a historic meeting, Kim Jong-un has
become the first North Korean leader to visit
the south since the Korean war.
Families split either side of the Ethiopian-Eritrean
border finally able to speak to each other
for the first time in decades.
Far right candidate Jair Bolsonaro has won
Brazil’s presidential race.
Jacob Zuma will step down as South Africa’s president.
The Irish people have voted in favor of scrapping
a constitutional ban on abortion.
This is about women taking their rightful
place in Irish society finally.
A Chinese researcher claims to have helped make the world’s first births of genetically
altered humans.
A data analysis firm linked to the Trump campaign
retained the personal information of more
than 50 million users.
We didn’t take a broad enough view of our
responsibility, and that was a big mistake.
17 people killed in connection with a mass shooting ...
A mass shooting at a Florida highschool... a synagogue in Pittsburgh...
The gunman opened fire...
I don't want prayers. I don't want thoughts. I want gun control and
Thousands of students are expected to walk
out of their schools — a mass protest across
the nation against gun violence.
A new report by the UN carries a stark warning. Millions more people will die from extreme
heat by the year 2040.
India’s Kerala state was hit by
the worst flooding it’s seen in a century.
A powerful, 7.5 magnitude earthquake struck  the
island of Sulawesi Friday.
Several separate enormous wildfires are taking
a terrible toll.
The stuff we lost isn’t as important as
the fact that our family’s all torn apart.
Yemen's humanitarian crisis is escalating
to devastating levels.
The United Nations warns up to 13 million
civilians are at risk of starvation.
The administration's new crackdown on illegal
immigration at the border, over a six week
period nearly 2,000 kids were separated from
nearly as many adults.
You know, they have a word. It sort of became old-fashioned.
It's called a "nationalist."
You know what I am? I'm a nationalist, okay.
In Paris, violent clashes erupted between
police and protesters for the third straight
weekend.
We pay so many taxes, it’s impossible now
to have a good life for us.
This is Jamal Khashoggi captured on closed
circuit cameras, stepping into what Turkish
authorities believe was a death trap.
I am here today not because I want to be.
Look at me when I’m talking to you. You’re
telling me that my assault doesn’t matter.
That what happened to me doesn’t matter.
Bill Cosby becomes the first celebrity to be convicted in the Me Too era.
I've dreamt of this day for 32 years.
Abusers: your time is up.
The survivors are here.
Standing tall.
Falling on your knees, praying.
What I know for sure is that speaking your
truth is the most powerful tool we all have.
So I want all the girls watching here and
now to know that a new day is on the horizon.
The midterm elections were full of historic
firsts.
The first muslim women… first Native American
women… first openly gay man elected governor…
It means something, to kids and people, to
see images that reflect themselves.
It's historical.
It moves me, like it moves me to tears.
That is going to have an impact, because imagery
does, you know, representation does.
France are the champions of the world!
All 12 boys and their soccer coach
have now been rescued from that flooded cave in Thailand.
An immigrant from Mali is being called a real
life Spider-Man after he rescued a child dangling
from a balcony.
Look at this.
You know, I guess one person can make a difference.
There are no limits to the human spirit.
Touchdown confirmed.
I believe what makes us unique is transcending
our limits.
I would much rather fail gloriously than not venture, not try.